Trascrizione: Eileen Castillo
Revisore: Michele Gianella
In effetti, noi questa sera
ripercorreremo la storia del rock,
vediamo una platea molto giovane.
Per molti di voi,
la storia del rock si ferma ai Måneskin,
inizia e finisce con i Måneskin.
In realtà, non è così.
La storia del rock è molto più lunga,
e noi questa sera
ve la racconteremo tutta.
La faremo macro, cioè dall'inizio,
da Elvis, i Beatles,
passando alla vita privata dei cantanti:
tutti i nomi dei gruppi,
fino ai Coldplay, ai Muse.
Sono sei ore e quaranta
di dissertazione, normalmente.
In realtà, stasera la storia, macro-micro,
la facciamo in cinque minuti.
Per fare la storia del rock
in cinque minuti,
abbiamo bisogno
di una rock band particolare.
Per esempio, dovremmo avere una chitarra,
una chitarra speciale
fatta solo con la voce,
vediamo un po'.
(Musica)
La chitarra c'è.
Poi serve la batteria: ce l'abbiamo?
(Musica)
La batteria c'è, splendido;
manca solo il basso.
(Musica)
Basta, il basso tanto fa solo questo.
Perfetto!
Allora abbiamo tutto:
siamo pronti, anzi prontissimi
per la nostra History of Rock.
Yeah!
(Applausi)